ich hatte ein schlechtes gewissen
gegenüber der schweiz weil ich hier zum
schluss einfach drogenabhängig
katastrophe war und dadurch zwangsläufig
genau die menschen die mir was bedeuten
und die liebevoll zu mir waren und gute
freunde genau die verprellt ab ich bin
gerade durch dieses leben
hingeflogen aus dem chor benjamin von
stuckrad-barre war ganz unten
damals nach dem plötzlichen erfolg als
pop literat
mit 23 wollte er hinein in den rausch
der nacht nahm drogen
jede menge drogen balancieren am abgrund
bis zum absturz
und nun sein buch panik herz eine
beichte ein kurzfristiges ziel war es
bloß keine sekunde nüchtern zu werden
weil ich wusste dass die traurigkeit
mich dann überwältigen würde ein
mittelfristiges ziel war kokain typisch
ein großprojekt das was mir immer am
wichtigsten gewesen war
meine musiksammlung und nun machte ich
mich daran sie zu zerstören
eine wilde zeit die stuckrad-barre da
beschreibt ein leben in dauer rock'n
roll alles ausprobieren
dazwischen schreiben fernsehen machen
mit speed auf der überholspur
ich finde das richtig an den rand zu
gehen und für jeden menschen ein glauben
und fünf künstler aber wirklich
notwendig sonst macht man bestenfalls
angenehmes kunsthandwerk aber wenn man
sachen herstellen will die etwas
bedeuten und die die auch andere
menschen berühren können dann muss man
durch den schmerz gehen so kitschig das
klingen dabei hätten ihn die
verlockungen des wilden lebens beinahe
umgebracht
das senior stürzte darauf startet von
vorn
in panik herz nimmt er uns auf knapp 600
seiten mit in seiner abstürze seine
entzugs torturen harte kost ist das doch
das ist auch die qualität des buches ich
taumelte die treppen hoch packte meinen
kram zusammen den ganzen müll und wohin
jetzt ich viel aufs bett krampfte mich
an der matratze fest als könnte ich so
die zeit anhalten
jetzt einfach hier liegen bleiben ich
weinte dramatisch und fügte mich dann in
den untergang
am tiefpunkt es dauerte zehn jahre bis
er darüber schreiben konnte ich habe
dieses buch ganz oft versucht zu
schreiben und bei mir übers scheitern
reden da bin ich oft daran gescheitert
ich wusste immer dass diese jahre der
sucht ein großes gutes thema sind zum
schreiben weil es eine existenzielle
eine note erfahrung ist
ausgerechnet in zürich nimmt er anlauf
über die drogen zeit zu schreiben
mit fatalen folgen ein versuch so 2004
da hab ich hier in zürich anfangen schon
mal über diese sucht zu schreiben im
schreiben plötzlich wurde das so
plastisch wieder dass ich einfach da war
die sucht zu stark hat gemerkt wie super
geschrieben offenbar ja es ist sehr
realistisch gewesen sagt die sucht von
ideen noch mal recherchieren als
benjamin von stuckrad-barre seinen
vierten in zug beginnt weiß er
dieses mal liegt kein rückfall drin die
ist so ein arschloch die suche panik
herz ist auch eine hommage an ihn udo
lindenberg einfach führer später ein
retter
habenicht
im nachgang zur panik herz
veröffentlicht benjamin von
stuckrad-barre jetzt den essay nüchtern
die ziehe ich meinen
ihr sagt positiv sagt cheers ich sage
nein danke